[Music]
let me welcome our first panel its
moderated by Robert digraph Robert is a
director of the Institute for Advanced
Study before he was president of so let
me make sure I have some words correctly
the Royal Netherland Academy of Arts and
Sciences actually not quite imaginable
for us in the Netherland here is a
regular TV star which sort of imagined
in the u.s. somebody who had the
scientific Institute being a TV star
where he is he also wrote a book which
is called the usefulness of useless
thinking and it was a shrinking
knowledge of useless knowledge and so we
ripped off their title a little bit for
our first panel which will be the
usefulness of long term thinking so let
me welcome to the podium Robert and his
panelists Matt Jackson yeah Kalai madhu
Sudan and a photographer
[Applause]
good morning it's a great pleasure to
have this panel and of course it should
start by congratulating Jennifer
Christian everybody here from Microsoft
for this wonderful success so you now
have a teenager and it's a good luck
with that I say as a parent the teenage
years are very challenging as they but I
hope that we see many many wonderful
things here so two great pleasure to
welcome with this first panel with this
wonderful title the usefulness of long
term thinking or the technical title was
the usefulness of long term thinking at
9:00 a.m. which is it's kind of a
challenge I must say when I issued the
book and I talked about his useless
knowledge as one of the jokes walls in
this time you know in this political
climate we need a kind of a prequel
which is the usefulness of useful
thinking perhaps we need a kind of a
children's version of that well coloring
plays something to make clear but I
think this will be very exciting we will
be kind of talking I must say also are
we were instructed to set the bar not
too high in our first panel so that the
other panels can shine and but in some
sense we are doing something quite
special because we will be thinking
about thinking and about theory the role
of theory and and some sense also in
this kind of this great environment
that's kind of created here and and
clearly you know both Jennifer and
Christian I know you have something with
you really not quite what it is but
you're so I just me just briefly
introduce my panel members so start here
with yellow collides he's actually your
local some sense both here at Microsoft
and also at MIT computer scientist
cryptography is one of your fields then
another more or less local module as
Sudan of course to theoretical computer
scientist worked on many areas proof
checking etc is now at Harvard then
match action fest of economics at
Stanford
behavioral economics game to you we
these are some of your interests and
then finally Ava Ava Tardos at Cornell
mathematician combinatorial mathematics
algorithmic game to you we got some of
your interests so a lot of brainpower
here on stage and I think I wanted to
start by kind of asking each of you to
say perhaps share one example of a
unexpected advantage of thinking of
theory that you perhaps came as a
surprise to you to start with you thanks
for waking me up i oh yeah we should be
closer to the audience there was one of
my goals so I've been at Microsoft I had
been at Microsoft a few years in the
past five years at least and yet my
biggest contribution to Microsoft was
not any of my own work here but rather a
student that I contributed to the
Microsoft Research environment survey
econo now he had been one of the most
purest of theoreticians that I ever knew
when Silicon Valley made the mistake of
hiring him I wrote to them very you know
thankful thanking them for their
generosity this is obviously going to be
so useful to him and to the world of
theory and it turned out that once he
was in Microsoft Research he started
getting engaged in problems related to
storage on the cloud over time along
with a very group of active researchers
and was very important that theory was
not sitting isolated on its own they
started interacting with other
researchers trying to understand what
were some challenges in distributed
storage you want your data tell us a
little bit what kind of theoretical
ideas for it
Bronks to that to the pro the whole idea
prior to his involvement in this
research was if we want to replicate
data so that you can live with crash
failures you must just completely
identically directly replicate things
everywhere and people were aware of the
idea of error correcting codes which
don't usually do this blind replication
but somehow try to recover from faults
by more efficient methods but they
always thought that this is
contradictory to the idea of recovering
the data very quickly after a failure
and Sergei brought in this perspective
coming from the world of theory that
instant recovery of data or fast
recovery of data is not in contradiction
with sophisticated storage mechanisms
and you put the two together you know
very soon everybody realized this was
actually practically viable could you
say that some sense the mitigation comes
to mind something you know it's kind of
interesting that the kind of field of
information something was also born in
in theory in theory absolutely and in
many of these cases we have seen somehow
periodically time and again if when you
abstract a problem come up with some
very complicated long-term vision of
this is how I want to solve problems in
the limit you also end up with matching
complementarity instantly in Shannon's
paper is probably one of the first error
correcting codes actually reported and
that was just a by the way we can also
do these things concretely and
throughout there is this method synergy
between the theory in the practice that
of course on the one hand you want to
think about the long term limits at the
same time you cannot but help produce
useful work for the near future
yeah I'm not skipping you but some
examples from your field
[Music]
many groups that are kind of working on
it right now and trying to interesting
fact because it might actually remove
some of our national buys because I
think certain areas we have very little
right it's I don't know if it's a theme
or not it's it's very it's a good
this is great number theorist center
often they are the applications of
number theory to cryptography is that
these are basically very difficult
problems to solve right so he he made
this point that you know number theory
was always seen as to complete the you
know Hardy sentence the most useless
thing ever ended throw why so beautiful
and this method it is he wants to kind
of solve these number theory problems to
liberate his beloved number right so
actually that's a very good point
actually
okay what what is useful then I have a
conjecture they can't solve turns out
that's all cryptography is based on that
without that we wouldn't have crypto so
and that's a very actually basic example
of and yeah all of cryptography is based
on I mean most of it on number theory
some of it and elliptic curve style
which is also something the lytic form
of number theory and it's all based on
hard conjectures and the hardness of of
problems that people don't know how to
solve so he actually if he you know he
succeeds an admission I'll be out of a
job what kind of examples did you bring
for us really understand and structure a
lot of problems where people have
different interest
they come together in all sorts of
different settings and interact and if
you trace back the the real seminal
confident contribution it was John
Nash's you know 1951 paper where he he
basically set up the problem so if you
look before that von Neumann and
Morgenstern really started in the 20s
but you know they sort of set the
structure and they set the structure in
terms of zero-sum games and it was very
elegant mathematically but it didn't it
wasn't the right setting to actually
apply too many settings where people
have interests but they're actually
gains from from interacting right so
most of the situations were in there the
the fact that we come together we act
there's synergies there's better we're
better off acting together than than
apart and and so zero-sum games don't
capture 99 percent of the settings we're
in and Nash basically set the structure
of he proved existence of an equilibrium
point but the the more fundamental
contribution was just setting the
problem up and saying here's the action
spaces here you know people can take
different actions they get payoffs from
these we set it up we and now we find a
solution and the the fascinating part
about it was if you look at what was
going on in the 1950s this was a branch
of mathematics and the Social Sciences
were completely separate from it nobody
had any idea that this was going on and
if you fast forward you go into the say
the 1970s and 80s that's when it started
to be picked up and it wasn't really you
know if you look at say the 1980s you'll
see papers by say Milgram and Weber that
use this to then develop understandings
of how auctions work right in an auction
somebody's selling something there's
different buyers that value it at
different things there's different
values that can come out of that that's
not a zero-sum game you know if you get
it in the right buyers hands it's more
valuable than the wrong buyers hands how
do they bid against each other so this
gave them the tools to understand that
and then fast-forward again and you look
at the you know the the spectrum
auctions that run by the FCC and so
forth and those are based on these these
theories and when after Nash won the
Nobel Prize he dad mu if you he had
mental illness for quite a while and who
his sort
of completely out of it and had never
seen what had been developed from his
theory there was an interview with Roger
Myerson interviewed Nash after the Nobel
price and he asked them you know isn't
it amazing that your theory has come so
far and now it's basically transforming
the way that we study things and things
like actions are now being done analyzed
using your structure and you said you
know what do what do options have to do
with you had no idea of the connection
and and sometimes when we're doing
theory it's very hard to see where you
know where that I would like the others
practice exactly it's just kind of tiny
but you know who cares about and somehow
you know that it was the client you know
the abstraction in the clean structure
that was very flexible that made it
powerful and once eventually the social
science could make use of that framework
that's the real contribution is to say
nothing as useful as I want to create
some diversity there for theoretical
happened for you know 20 or 30 or more
years is approximation of it oh man some
poor monsters have to be computationally
hard then and furious there are serious
issues idea that ok how close can I get
to the optimum and they're there you
know certainly in the early years there
in the fall of this missile
and you know and this is coming back as
a team over and over again sort of along
the lines that you're all mentioned in a
different context like if you use in the
early years beyond actually an
understanding of so much much better
operating than 10 years or maybe more
than that I have been working a lot in
game theory and this approximation
algorithm framework got translated into
what's over there
referred to the price of energy that is
taking a system
you know
[Music]
okay doing it selfishly there because
it's not so much worse than we optimum
then it's reasonable to you know don't
bother with designing graphics like very
careful writing systems this sort of you
know everyone choosing a short as
possible but we are missing and I hope
we can evaluate example this guarantee
of good it is and at the moment there
are very few examples of this sort of
price of energy on a particular instance
but we do a salmon developing field and
I guess this is sort of pushing the more
abstract theory to something that really
is there something perhaps on you write
write something to fill people's minds
you know this either the usefulness or
something or it is the intellectual
death the kind of adds up to a hundred
percent something so uh if there's
something like almost a curse of
usefulness in the sense that if you're
working something that everybody feels
me be clear this has great applications
that you have to fight somehow to also
get out the theory behind it
I think actually the end of the day it's
up and I'm kind of a cling to your
question - why you smelling to your
earlier question that I think at the end
of the day what's really what is very
useful yes the end of they often these
are just beautiful ideas it's a
beautiful idea when your goal is just to
kind of get something out there now like
you know oh I want them to that'd be the
fastest now you're not actually looking
for something you know you're you just
you saw this in it it's not about than a
beautiful idea and I think the things
that last the things that are I don't
know to me it's like like a probable
proof it's just a beauty of thank you
can I dig a little deeper here because I
can't notice that we here on the family
use Beauty beautiful ideas we only
create you have to get put in a room I
know just like artists if you think
about a beautiful idea I to kind of
secretly already seeing that this will
be have like many ramifications or
something or can you just try to put a
few words how you want capture that view
yeah so it's a good question so since
you're asking can you define what
beautiful wings is the notion of
Colorado central idea I can tell you
what in in some sense what did not it's
a little bit when it's something that is
solving a question that's there now that
needs to be solved but if someone else
does it it kind of nothing is left you
know so if I could seem solving but
somewhere else other than a different
approach he does better what I did
becomes useless are not interesting
anymore that's not a beautiful I guess
even when someone else doesn't different
and it's better than me that gets to
live and if it's really a good one a
beautiful women then you will find its
place elsewhere so long-term useful we
summarized the final question about
economics because just a little anecdote
world's worst added fork of an economist
and I was with a friend of mine who
studies medieval no alchemy do cetera
and just you know it's like in a sense
this point was that no sometimes new
phenomics is like hyper science or
something you know it's is this the song
so how people can be captured by the
models etc and so the models of
determining the real world
it's not anything like this awful
overshoot so to say or theories or
models in economics because in the end
you're also dealing with the real world
and determining people's lives what's
important in any field this understand
where models work well on where they
don't and understanding exactly how
fairly simple economic systems work you
know if you increase people's wages
where are they going to spend the money
if you're changing tax rates what's
going to happen to labor supply these
kinds of things are well understood
they're not sexy they don't appear in
the news but the kinds of things that
people are interested in is when's the
next financial crisis going to hit you
know that that's hard to predict now
you've got a very complex system you've
got all kinds of interacting things the
modeling is is not very good people are
going to be willing to stand up there
and give opinions and and you know by
its very nature people have to make
predictions and so economics is used for
as a predictive science as well as one
to basically understand systems and to
evaluate policies but I think its
strengths are not in the areas that
appear in the media but more in areas
that are sort of nuts and bolts kinds of
things you know if you want to design a
new system for for you know getting out
of a program and developing
country what's a good way to incentivize
people to participate these are kinds of
questions where you know economists are
making progress and and so forth it's
very different from predicting the next
world recession or you know these kinds
of things and so you know you get this
idea that it's alchemy and and so forth
from from looking at people
pontificating and going way beyond the
reach of the models but there's areas
where the models apply very well it
reminds me yes although I think was in
nature of science a few months ago and
the title was machine learning is the
new alchemy and I want to ask all of you
a little bit about the world of data etc
so I think you know as many of you have
a background in computer science I mean
that's kind of a wonderful field because
of somewhat started in theory right it's
a bit touring and go at all etc and and
it can by the way fascinating started
with negative results something and then
it led to this blossoming field now we
also live in a world of big data machine
learning AI as something where it looks
almost like you you can fit and why why
do we need Theory anymore if at some
point we have a machine that will be
fitting patterns and and if you want to
kind of start the discussion around that
topic you know things are not this very
simple yet the fact that Nash
equilibrium and
an immense impact because it's such a
simple Syria and so many so much insight
is really coming from this machine
learning at this point is less good in
understanding where the limits are in
understanding of what this machine
learning systems can do and why
realization spinning will have an
immense improvement you know machine
learning is really popular right now a
lot of people are thinking exactly
[Music]
so there are sort of interesting
challenges challenges that I think again
many of us are working on Oh what
happens if I take the mesh kind of
equilibria my DS but combined with is
that the players are all you know
developer extend the theory in this
direction which I think another thing so
you is your guest that these ideas will
come from the fields itself or that we
need just like Nashville's coming
completely from left field you know as a
abstract mathematician
working on this right now and more
coming from computer science this lab is
an example they said Chiefs are
happening but there's a whole conference
out there under the name of economic
cycle if you think a lot of these people
get together their lips which is one of
the big machine learning conference is
last year had a workshop on learning and
games this is an interesting application
of a word learning games are just
happening yes we're also but I saw the
lips posted one of them was that lips
except lips and the community understood
the importance of why do you you have
thoughts about it so first a little bit
about you know when you say if things
are working well then why do we need
theory things the fact that things are
working well say something about the
past and it says about things that we
problems that we tried to invent that we
encountered in the past where we're able
to solve them when I mean even the
company like Microsoft likes to think
about the future and say well we're
gonna sell this piece of hardware this
software this platform it should be
working any errors into the future and
when you want to have this
predictability you do have to have a
theory it might be very elementary not
the most of the stated stuff that we are
always working with but it should be
able to have some predictive power and
this is roughly what we are always
working to striving towards and the
simpler the predictive power gets the
more theoretical the answer that's my
definition of theory beauty everything
is yeah you know the more you can
actually say take an idea and apply it
in multiple situations this is good so
the other handicap with working with the
problem that you are set today is you
forget about the potential
generalizations of a solution that you
may have discovered
and I mean of course machine learning is
an entire theory of generalizability but
I would even say that look this is what
drives all of our you know theoretical
inspiration we want to take ideas from
here applied there in order to go from
this point to that point we have to find
some common abstraction which actually
combines these two but also ends up
including a lot more in the fold so I
think theory is interesting and I
consider any work which does this kind
of an abstraction theoretical I mean
anything that we can teach is
theoretical something that is not living
purely in a system that we have
hard-coded which I cannot ever remember
again is as Yael was describing
those are not theory for me but when we
can try to abstract something go beyond
the limits of what has been described
today those are fantastic things for
theory so I think this is what we are
striving for sort of you know simple
ideas which explain a lot and have the
potential or the possibility to explain
a lot into the future
one more point then I'll pass it over I
mean a comment that I heard from a
statistician recently and I just loved
it when I heard it was all models are
wrong some are useful this is a moment
to if you're still or you're ready awake
to get a few questions from the audience
and I will con try to kind of get the
next round of reactions I think it I
don't microphones is there we have to
yeah you don't even have to run high
well thank you very much it was very
great okay I'm recent PhD graduated from
Boston University and we're somebody
joining this tree
so I'm an I've worked in machine
learning and information theory both and
to me information theory is one of those
beautiful ideas because no one can once
it's proven no one can says it's wrong
and so I feel like it shows the path to
the future and and because you said we
need prediction for like all these
learning algorithms
it was wondering what is the connection
between these two fields because maybe
information here you could be could use
useful tool for predicting what are the
limits of any are specific architectures
of learning algorithms what do you think
about this come back to it see what
other other questions we got somebody to
it another question is just a comment
because I think it relates a lot to the
last statement and to the question about
beauty directly because the models are
not just an interpretation of of the
world directly some artists that are
using economics models as a way to
interpret or express their own vision of
the world and then they actually tweak
them and caricature them as as an
abstract or has an impressionist will
actually time but its own personality in
the interpretation of the world and so
economic model actually become a form of
a beautiful this great command Chris
Bishop Fernandez our Cambridge why don't
you say a little bit about the
communication between theorists and not
themselves but the consumers of the
theory one thought I have in mind is so
I'm machine learning but I wouldn't
consider myself a theorist but I'm sort
of interested in the consumer theory if
you like you know one piece of theory
from the second wave of neural Nets was
the the theorem that two layers of
neurons are sufficient to approximate
any function to arbitrary accuracy and
of course it's a it's a proven rigorous
theorem so it's correct it's not going
to change and yet it's perhaps it did it
distract people from thinking about deep
learning how do we how should we
interpret
we come to it
yeah great so yeah I would like to start
with the this kind of last question
which I can almost rephrase so so there
is there many elements to it that I want
to come back perhaps the first element
that you know sometimes theory can
suggest something and then progress
being made to go around it or something
right so it could be so anybody wants to
perhaps technically answer that question
why the two-layer network didn't prevent
thinking so deep learning Paulo fire to
give an understandable one thing that I
see definitely is that you know when you
know we answer questions in the theory
land they are often precisely formulated
we answered the precise question that
was asked but then there was something
else in the background saying oh but I
always meant something else and that was
not abstracted into the question and the
answer completely fails to get to that
point so there is a constant interaction
which is why you know it's not the case
that every theoretical paper sort of
changes the world there is a constant
interaction between the applications and
the theory in these kinds of settings
and many times I would suspect in the
deep neural Nets also we forgot some
aspect of yes we wanted to you know
maybe approximate every function but it
also has to be learner will by some
simple mechanism the kinds of data that
is available may not be captured by the
kind of data that was used to prove the
depth to result so we have lots of
different possibilities on what could
vary the interesting aspect of theory is
that we throw a lot of these details in
order to solve the problem but the
details start to become important and
rise to prominence once you've saw on
the first problem I guess we taking
extreme limits all agree the world just
run by theorists not goods and no things
also no good so somehow in between I can
and if you say something about what this
should be kind of the right ecosystem
it's almost like how if you want to
structure a world where there is all
these different kind of niches and how
should they are so they communicate some
ideas
so actually very interesting ecosystem
sorry of the theorists on the one hand
and someone should try to move from take
things from theory land to practice land
this is kind of middle person these
middle people who are supposed to
deliver is a very very very important
group and I think that you have to be
bilingual at the theory community strong
tap location of the people who apply
things are strong but in the middle the
people that actually move and the reason
is what first often you know we have
models for each game Syrian National
Review
to every economist every University yeah
sure definitely if you take theory
that's getting developed you know last
ten years
right now and if that's going about
short-term or immediate or even the next
ten years impact on industry then
definitely I'm not objecting we do these
people who I do want some basic CRA me
but basic understanding to actually
migrate to literally everyone so oh we
can capture that I think that was the
idea you can have an beautiful theorem
that kind of finishes the field so to
say and actually the field can go around
it then we have many examples reason why
there was a really long term effect and
yeah of course not everyone should work
on the longest one theory
but I think we need to strive that some
basic theory and elegant beautiful
series that explained a lot of what's
going on in the bird that should be out
there
thank you agree on nothing yeah I was
gonna say I think one way to put it is
that that people should think like
theorists so that that theory forces you
to understand what are the key things I
want to focus on I can't do everything
at once so I have to distill things into
you know some set of variables that I
think you're gonna really be important
and then I have to attack the problem in
a systematic way and I think you know
one of the so obviously research is
Spanish and it makes sense that you know
people go all too you know that now
there's an intense interest in machine
learning and it makes sense for a lot of
people to be working on it and there's
synergies there and and but at the same
time you know pattern recognition isn't
going to be the only thing that works
you have to know what you're looking for
and as Manu said you know you're
thinking about the future the system's
gonna change so you need some structure
of how is the system gonna change how do
I make predictions about the future in
completely unseen versions of the
current world we haven't been talking
about long-term thinking so clearly you
know we're in the first decade of the
lab so 10 years seems to be a life a
lifetime but if you are if you look at
your own fields and something so what is
the lifespan of truly deep ideas are we
talking about many decades and then the
question comes you know how do we
sustain these kind of ideas I love the
idea matter which you were saying that
something theory is also very helpful
because it's something we can teach that
you can kind of can transfer to the next
generation all right which is very
difficult from just kind of experiences
there are some some ideas about what the
timespan is and what's kind of necessary
to bridge that these long time
how do you keep a theory alive so to say
okay I think here we defer to the you
know the sociological aspects of the
field and let the people more or less
this I have socialist friends in the
audience I think I mean for the most
part we just tend to leave this to
personal taste and the activity levels
that is sustainable by a field and we do
needs personal choice is completely
independent because there is some extent
driven by external factors absolutely I
think we have to see the questions that
are driving the field we have to see
some of the ability to make progress on
the questions just saying here are you
know problems that have been open for
the last 500 years and we're gonna work
on this for the next ten years doesn't
seem to be you know a good way well the
good news about even this kind of an
approach I could try this approach and I
will not be able to recruit students
into this field so I think there is a
pretty strong phenomenon where students
the new people entering the field tend
to also take us in different directions
and this often ends up being the most
you know primal force and so who can we
recruit I mean today we see excellent
people who will you know train this
theoretical computer scientists drifting
towards machine learning why is this
happening because there are important
problems there there are challenges
there and we are not going to drop
everything we know but we are not going
to work on the same old problems
necessarily when there are so many other
compelling things so this is a live
field and it's served there are some
young people here the audience I can
trigger any of the kind of graduate
students here or something but what they
think about a role or theory and long
term long term issues I see graduate
students ryder good comment i love the
panel by the way give you a quick
scenario which is a little bit different
we went hammering on a problem since
1998 on ideal web crawl and it's gone
through
some Theory some practice empirical
tests we finally hit upon the most
theoretical analysis of this and it's
the most practical and going into
service
it took us it took us literally we
didn't know kind of constantly but
intermittently hammering on this for
twenty years and only having a lab like
this and thank God Redman is 27 years
old
we we actually foster different teams of
power busts in this case so working with
you follow and I yell Lipetsk II and so
on we got to the theory that was most
practical if a kind of particulars I
would like to give you an example of a
good case of long-term thinking which
actually was at the Institute for
Advanced Study the mathematician
Vladimir for Volsky you in Fort Lee
passed away last year but he was a great
algebraic geometer got the Fields Medal
then found a mistake in one of his
papers he was very surprised to find a
mistake but even more surprised that
nobody cared and then he thought well I
have to rewrite the foundations of
mathematics so that the computers can
actually understand in his case abstract
home were talking theory and so he then
spent ten years essentially without
producing any paper and it's I would say
no it's like a whale diving very deep in
and at some point you're worried well
will he come back to the surface and he
did and and I think was quite a
successful program and it might have a
big impact but makes me think you know
do we have places where somebody can be
underwater for ten years or something
and yet we all benefit not producing
anything are you worried that people
come out if somebody spends ten years
thinking about it you and you find it
goes amiss well and your advantage which
is it's terrific to
they're also less amazing and less
famous some sort of long-term thing like
good research doesn't necessarily solve
the fundamental problem of the field of
the universe because there are very few
results of that sort so most days day in
and day out all of us cannot each of us
cannot or I cannot produce results of
that sort but I have to write an
introduction that explains why do you
need to care about you know Vice is the
step in a possible direction where there
is a big hill that we really care about
and I admit the machine learning people
now have it easy there is a very big
clear big hill over there but everything
we're working on we are constantly
pushed to explain the goal and that's
usually interest of all of our papers
and these are this people sometimes do
that and occasionally they're successful
but I think sometimes they laugh and I
really like that I'm getting forced and
I guess there is a one example from my
early years that I have been pretty
public about where I wrote the paper in
the break after I gave the talk lots he
loved us very very gently and very
politely came over then yes but I do
care I forgot many years till I even
wrote down the results I did write it
down it is actually published in Journal
of JCT journal I mean serious thank you
it was a large paper but I sort of I
think I learned a lesson and this is the
lesson I promote is that we need to
think even before we get involve why do
we care and I guess he knew why
occurred because he was so famous and
and and well established the community
trusted him but I think the fact that we
regularly have to write about our
partial results and explain that this is
a good call has two giant benefits one
it makes us think about this which is
good and second we recruit our friends
or our colleagues to help this much of
the results that you're achieving are
not a single person's achievement it's
it's a you know anything that the two of
them talked about for crypto or
from-from error-correcting code there's
a community working on this you know I
agree with you completely that you need
to have a goal in mind that you think is
worth is worth but now the goal can be
every one of those should spend now you
know go ten years underwater and and
think deeply but some some people should
because we need some good ideas and it's
it's dangerous I actually one comment on
that I think you know look stepping back
a bit when we think about who supports
research and what they're you know why
they support it and what their goals are
that's a very difficult part of research
right because there's a huge value in
these deep dives and new discoveries
that are going to be transformative many
years later and often those aren't the
ones that are gonna have immediate
payoffs and so you need large benevolent
organizations like Microsoft or
universities or something that are
willing to fund labs that are you know
allow people to take deep dives and
that's not
you know often they have a risk they
have to spend so many yeah I think
somehow it's difficult research is done
in a very self organized system right
it's is people out there just doing what
they want and and there's some
incentives and in carrots and you know
ten year and you have to keep producing
at some level and you have to justify
what you're doing and so there's there's
landmarks and and goals but the the
overall picture of how we're invested in
who's doing what there's very little
coordination it's just like a lot of you
know humans like ants marching around
all doing their thing and hoping that we
coordinate and produce good things and
there's enough of us that good things
happen but mine is that we are taking a
wide spectrum of people over here and
then going to the very very very tail
ends to determine you know these are the
people who want to be researchers
applying the the theory of
predictability which is supposed to be
somewhere sitting around the middle of
the bell curve to population which is
sitting in the extreme seems to be
really dangerous to me and unfortunately
this is getting practiced too commonly
in universities tenure systems promotion
cases etc and we really have to be very
about it so every one of us knows by
personal familiarity that the the people
that they admire we're not the ones who
sort of is the matrix these are the ones
that came up with
ideas and probably came up in the
brilliant ideas almost out of nowhere at
the same time to see should we now try
to manage this process is very dangerous
I love by the way the Microsoft motto or
you know principles by which they were
hiring and they were managing the
research labs which was we decide who we
hired we don't decide what they do I
think was a wonderful principle and I
hope you're gonna continue this it was
when I was here and after that I forgot
but I mean I think it's fair to say that
you know both that principle and the
long-term goal and is great to be here
with an organization that values this
but I hear a lot of complaints that you
know some sense that's open space is
shrinking you know that for instance 50
years ago even big we'd famously at Bell
Labs and other places that were
producing many many Nobel Prizes and
somehow had more oxygen or something
that then typically now you see around
if you agree is the world getting better
it's getting different so there is such
a thing happening just I think you know
humans are good at reaction to crises
they're not good at long term
investments and thinking and it's a
really difficult thing to do to sort of
say look we want to we want us fund this
it's gonna be great you know let all
these people take deep dives and we'll
see 30 years from now what happens
instead you know you're looking at you
know we've got this pressing problem and
and let's let's solve it so it's a very
difficult thing to do and and the
funding becomes essential because these
kinds of things can't be done without
that kind of fun
I object to issues we are raising the
big diamonds in going into an area which
doesn't you know produces interesting
amazing things and not necessarily have
immediate impact I don't think the
pressure to publish or pressure to talk
about partial results and you know
sometimes some people think it their own
way and I object
but the positive impact the very very
same thing is that when you publish your
pressure results two words are because
then usually there's a whole community
out there who suddenly sees that good
point the core might be reachable I let
me work on there is a you know there's a
hope out there so you you you partial
result are recruiting a community which
is not against the the main goal well I
think we are getting close to to the end
of this first perhaps it one more
question yes please and then we'll
finish okay do you think the the lag
will change now that people are
communicating better there's no longer
necessarily a 30-year lag between some
the time that somebody has a great
theoretical result in its applied yeah
perhaps that's a good question and I now
finished by do each of us you very short
question about whether the but it's kind
of the future of thinking of how do you
see perhaps mention one like one element
that might change the nature of Theory
the nature of long-term thinking when we
are looking in the future Sophie here in
ten years celebrating 20 years of
allowed what will be different make a
quick answer to the atom and this is
actually Kevin Layton Browns in the
audience and we've done a MOOC together
two moves together and I think now the
dissemination of knowledge is is really
amazing and you know being able to teach
game theory to people around the world
and large scale that they would never
have had access to means that there's a
very different landscape that we don't
quite understand yet but it's very very
encouraging when people who otherwise
would have
access to this kind of knowledge can now
be become part of the team become
recruited and and help producing future
knowledge that's going to advance the
society so also a quick sort of reaction
to Adams question I think as we are
communicating better faster I'd say not
necessarily better one of the advantages
is of course you hear all the good news
very quickly also hear all the fake news
very quickly and this does not apply
only to realm's like politics censorship
so society it's also applying to
scientific results we all heard about
the proof of the Riemann hypothesis a
few weeks back and these kinds of events
I mean we do have to worry a lot about
there is a lot of material being
generated simply the volume is very high
even if you have infinite bandwidth
coming in there's sort of limited
bandwidth going into my brain so I think
we're going to have you know this will
be a process which will you know some
things become better maybe your
geographical distance from the center of
the discovery is no longer as relevant
but having intellectual mass at the
place where you are it's still going to
be relevant you are alone in this you
know isolated place you can be very well
connected on the web to every piece of
development and still not really get it
Ava machine learning is the next
excellent be really very this is really
happening more powerfully by the time
people submit their paper in machine
learning to nip sir I see a man usually
it has some insane number of citations
because they put it on archive first and
people are ready started to work on
follow up and using it is amazing and I
think I don't know if we ever as fastest
as the the machine learning community is
but this speed of people reacting to
each other siding improving I think we
all have science go further so
okay terrific well I want to thank all
of you for being awake and participating
and so I think in the kind of self
congratulatory nature of academics we
want to kind of celebrate this wonderful
institution here and happy 10th
anniversary thank you
[Applause]